we learned yesterday that the nation's
largest abortion provider Planned
Parenthood abused this emergency process
and grabbed tens of millions of dollars
of taxpayer money for which they were
completely completely ineligible 27 GOP
senators urging Attorney General Bill
Barr to investigate Planned Parenthood
yeah this after a fox news exclusive
reveals the abortion provider was given
eighty million dollars in PPP loans here
to weigh in on the cash grab fallout is
constitutional attorney Harmeet Dillon
good to see you this morning thanks for
being here happy to be here thank you
of course now as we know as we've been
told that any companies with fewer than
500 employees are eligible for PPP
Planned Parenthood says that their
affiliates qualify for the loans to that
what do you say well I think it's
completely inappropriate that these
affiliates which are clinics throughout
the United States that perform largely
abortions violated the law the law that
put this program into place requires
that the companies that apply for it
have to demonstrate that they have a
need that they're affected negatively by
kovat in fact throughout the majority of
the United States many of these most of
these clinics were actually able to keep
doing abortions they weren't affected
they were one of the few that were not
affected and so they lied in fact to
banks and they lied under this federal
program and and they should give the
money back here's a letter from 27
different GOP senators in part we urge
you to investigate the activities of
dozens of Planned Parenthood affiliates
this is the bill bar the Paycheck
protection program was designed to help
struggling small businesses not to give
government funds to politicize partisan
abortion providers Planned Parenthood
says that this is purely political harm
meat and they say that they were
eligible for this your response to their
perspective well many other big
companies taking the politics out of it
and taking the abortion out of it a lot
of big companies got their hand caught
in the cookie jar they took the money
because they thought it was free and big
banks gave it away to them but this is a
zero-sum game to be very clear every one
of the eighty million dollars at Planned
Parenthood took which they were not
entitled to means tens of thousands of
small businesses that are mom-and-pop
businesses that need
money that was the purpose for which it
was granted by the government didn't get
it there's only a limited amount of
money and so that's really what's at
stake here Planned Parenthood took money
off of the plates of people who really
needed it and they should be ashamed and
they should give it back and it's
illegal well you're seeing on the screen
right now that 37 of their affiliates
received the 80 million dollars in loans
let's go to this direct quote from
Planned Parenthood and this reads quote
it is nothing to do with Planned
Parenthood health care organizations
eligibility for COBIT 19 relief efforts
and everything to do with the Trump
administration using a political agenda
and distract from their own failures in
protecting the American public from the
spread of Cova 19 but her me this is a
little different than what they said
back in March if we go to this this is a
quote from March 25th and this reads the
bill gives the Small Business
Administration broad discretion to
exclude Planned Parenthood affiliates
and other nonprofits serving people with
low incomes and deny them benefits her
me what do you think changed between
March 25th and now well let me tell you
how this program really operated I'm a
small business owner and I went through
this process if you had a good
relationship with a bank they kind of
looked the other way it's easier to
process a large contribution to an
existing lender or an existing customer
than a small mom-and-pop that maybe was
standing on its own two feet and never
needed a loan that's what happened so
they took advantage of this program and
shame on the banks to the banks have a
gateway gatekeeper role there they were
supposed to make sure that people signed
off that they need it and they proved it
they haven't done that and it's not just
Planned Parenthood there's some big
companies that did it and you know
they've got called out by Treasury and
they gave the money back Planned
Parenthood should do the same
yeah they've had to really fix a lot of
problems there with the PPP and the way
the banks handled the small businesses
you're right about that let's move on to
cope at 19 about the vaccinations here
for a second everybody's getting really
excited of the possibility that this
fall we could have a lot of these
vaccines available the idea that maybe
we might have to take this vaccine we
might be mandated to here's Alan
Dershowitz the vaccine is extremely safe
then the state does have a right to tell
you to take it look if you don't want to
take the vaccine you have an option you
can stay in quarantine well you don't
have the right to do is circulate inside
without being vaccinated hermie what do
you think about this the idea that they
might force you to take this needle well
I think there's another part of this
interview or another one rate
colourfully says that if you don't want
to take the vaccine they will grab your
arm and they will jab a needle into you
that's actually not you know United
States law it is correct that that they
can restrict you from certain activity
so we're all familiar with schools if
children are not vaccinated because
their parents don't believe in it they
can't go to the public schools and there
may be other areas where you're
restricted but we do have individual
liberty and autonomy under the
Constitution but you know Society has
some interest as well I think it's gonna
be a little dicey to expect a lot of
Americans to take a vaccine that is
barely tested and has just hastily been
rolled out I'm not really frankly eager
to take it until a few million people
taken and they don't drop dead and then
we'll see what happens but you know what
is rational to take vaccines after
they've been tested and I'm not I'm not
really comfortable with the way this is
being pushed in that regard if now it's
great for some people young people
healthy people but if you have
respiratory issues or older you know you
might want to wait and see how it how it
goes yeah be the be scared be the first
person in the pool on this with without
fastest being developed I agree with
that Hartman thank you so much right
appreciate it happy to be here thank you